quando a sua voz ea sua visão interior
forem mais ondas nítidas e audíveis do
que qualquer opinião perna você terá
enfim dominado a sua vida linda noite a
todas a todos e honra estar aqui
gratidão porém as palavras de john de
martini e fazem lembrar que todos os
dias eu tenho a oportunidade de
conversar com pessoas bem sucedidas como
dizemos pessoas bem sucedidas que possui
tela casa um bom carro
uma brastemp preta 540 litros
daquela com dispenser de água e gelo na
porta sabe um ótimo cargo um maravilhoso
ciclo de amigos mas que no fundo possui
lacunas de autoconfiança
algumas delas são reféns das opiniões
dos outros ou simplesmente acham que não
são boas o corretas o suficiente então
vivem fazendo sempre mais em busca
daquilo que talvez nunca venha a crença
de que são capazes de algo ou de que
merece aquilo que possui
talvez muitos de nós aqui já tenhamos
passado por crises como esta mas a minha
experiência dos últimos anos na área de
treinamento desenvolvimento e coaching
me leva a acreditar que estamos passando
por uma crise coletiva e estrutural de
autoconfiança
mesmo que não seja isso que nós
presenciamos todos os dias nas redes
sociais
bom vamos entender por um outro ângulo
essa história
há mais ou menos uns 30 dias
eu fui convidado para dar uma entrevista
e contar um pouquinho sobre a minha vida
pessoal ea minha carreira profissional
logo no início da conversa me fizeram a
seguinte pergunta
fale um pouco sobre a sua infância após
um longo silêncio dos sentimentos me
vieram à mente tristeza e medo tristeza
porque o diego adulto não havia
conseguido acessar memórias de
felicidade da infância e medo porque eu
lembrei que foi o sentimento que mais me
ocorreu naquela época
sim fui uma criança muito medrosa
observe o meu rostinho tenso no sete de
setembro da pré-escola desfilava e
procurava minha mãe na multidão
para vocês terem uma idéia eu tinha
alguns medos pareciam muito bobos
eu tinha medo de ir de casa para a
escola tinha medo de ficar sozinha em
qualquer espaço até de galinha de angola
eu tinha medo porque sou eu no mesmo ano
na formatura da escola
observem que eu já era o mais alto da
turma o que já me rendi dia alguns bugs
é claro percebam que eu era o mais
deslocado e novamente a minha carinha de
cadeia
aqui meu aniversário de oito anos
esta aqui à esquerda de vocês é a cris
minha namoradinha
afinal de contas todo menino precisa de
uma namoradinha
na verdade essa foto também me trouxe
uma lembrança de um outro medo que eu
sentia o meio estranho sabe medo de uma
coisa que estava em mim mas eu não sabia
o que era não conseguia identificar ou
entender eu só sabia que essas cobranças
sociais como as namoradinhas por exemplo
me incomodavam profundamente
aos 16 lembro que já tornou o adu por
aquela angústia tremenda e portanto os
medos
eu me pegava constantemente querendo
dormir muito por dias talvez meses mas o
meu desejo era de que quando eu
acordasse tudo estaria bem
eu já conseguiria me relacionar de uma
forma tranquila com as pessoas e não
sentiria mais medo de mim mesmo
aos 17 começou o que eu chamo de uma
reviravolta do bem porque muitas pessoas
especiais começaram a cruzar meu caminho
minha psicoterapeuta angela um anjo de
pessoa
um dos meus padrinhos de vida e de
oratória prédio e alguns amigos da
igreja e do grupo de jovens todas as
ações de incentivo que essas pessoas
tinham para comigo me traziam uma
segurança muito grande sabe e eu
começava a sentir vibrar dentro de mim
uma força que eu ainda não tinha sentido
mas que era muito boa e hoje eu sei que
era força a autoconfiança
quanto mais eu me relacionava estreitava
os meus laços de relacionamento com
essas pessoas mas eu entendia sobre mim
mesmo passava gostar de mim conseguia
ter consciência dos meus talentos e a
minha vida se transformava de uma forma
magnífica
de lá pra cá e lá se vão
alguns aninhos algumas crises ainda me
visitaram é claro mas graças às outras
pessoas que estiveram comigo durante
esse período
aquela força interna sabe que começou a
vibrar dentro de mim
ela ainda cresce até hoje me dar uma
permissão silenciosa para acreditar que
eu sou capaz e merecedor de estar aqui
no palco do ted x centro universitário
funk
todas as experiências que eu vivi com
essas pessoas foram pautadas em um verbo
muito importante incentivar todos me
incentivaram da melhor maneira que
puderam hoje como coaching
eu acompanho pessoas rumo ao atingimento
de metas ajuda a essas pessoas a
elevarem a sua auto confiança e
encontrarem a satisfação profissional e
dentro deste processo eu faço com eles o
que fizeram comigo pelo incentivo
só que o atingimento de uma meta depende
da autoconfiança do dono desta meta
pra que ele acredite que é capaz de
construir o caminho rumo à ela
começamos então juntos uma a construção
de um processo de auto confiança
unindo a minha experiência de vida como
a prática profissional eu proponho pra
vocês nesta noite um modelo de
construção de auto confiança
levando em consideração que o principal
princípio é de que a autoconfiança ela
se constrói em relações
já que ela se constroem relações nós
todos nós aqui precisamos desenvolver
algumas habilidades humanas a fim de que
as 20 que possamos passar por este
processo
a primeira escada primeiro nível de
dessa construção uma autoconfiança é a
empatia ea compaixão e empatia é a
capacidade de você se enxergar por meio
do contexto de outra pessoa por meio dos
olhos de outra pessoa e compaixão é
quanto dentro de você existe uma vontade
de querer que a dor da pessoa minimize
diminua
sabe que quando eu falo dor mas se as
dores do dia a dia
a dor do término de um relacionamento
a dor de uma demissão inesperada a dor
do filho que está doente enfim dores e
quando consigo uma empatia e compaixão
eu chego na vontade genuína de ajudar e
para ir lá e aí pra nós entendermos um
pouco mais o que essa vontade de ajudar
me permita compartilhar com vocês um
pequeno vídeo começou a sentir suas
pernas falharem no finalzinho da corrida
na altura do quilômetro 39 dois
quilômetros à frente ela desmaiou
enquanto liderava a prova atrás dela
estava adriana luther mãe de 17 anos ela
participou de um dos trechos da prova
junto com outras atletas de sua escola
que fizeram uma equipe de revezamento
para a maratona
assim que viu chandler dão cambaleando
ariana não teve dúvida se pegou a
maratonista pelos braços e ajudou a
correr os metros restantes
e para completar ainda amparou a
psiquiatra pela linha de chegada para
que ela não vencesse a prova
choveu nem sequer compreender o que
estava acontecendo
ganhei questionou a atleta quando mais
voluntários apareceram para socorrê la
a única coisa que passou pela minha
cabeça foi ajudá-la explicou a diana
após o término da corrida
quantas vezes nós nos sentimos como esta
atleta
cansados confusos apenas querendo alguém
que nos ampare quantas vezes pessoas
cruzam os nossos caminhos
cansadas confusas precisando de apoio
mas nós estamos muito interessados na
nossa rotina do dia a dia para percebê
las e aí elas se tornam invisíveis e de
repente somos uma multidão de cansados
confusos e sozinhos mas quando alguém
tenha coragem de romper com esse status
code anestesia coletiva e realmente
perceber o outro
vejam o que acontece
[Aplausos]
a minha equipa laranja e eu e o op o que
me preocupa mesmo fez e da house of
choice melo não pode sair a não ser em
outro lugar é bem assim mas são tantos
que andam nos tente condição da ibersol
o game coloca nesse livro aqui o vila e
olha que ele tem são absoluta
quando a vontade eu já acontece
nós naturalmente nos conectamos
humanamente com as pessoas e abrimos
oportunidade para incentivá las
para vocês terem uma idéia do poder de
conexão de vocês perguntem se que os
outros se sentem perto de mim a resposta
desta pergunta que levará a em
termômetro digamos assim do seu poder de
conexão com as pessoas quanto maior o
seu poder de conexão mas as pessoas
gostam se sentem agradáveis confortáveis
perto de você pra que sim você possa
incentivá las mas como contando uma
história sua aparecida com o que a
pessoa está passando ensinando a fazer
alguma coisa questionando sobre suas
possíveis dúvidas ou simplesmente se
colocando à disposição
e aí quando você tem vontade de ajudar
quando você se conecta incentivar
pessoas
ela consegue ter autonomia para
alimentar a sua auto confiança e acaba
se tornando nossa
um autor chamado buttman em um trecho de
seus livros diz o seguinte são as
pessoas que nos colocam no mundo
são elas que nos dão de comer que nos
pés tem que cuidar de nós quando nós
estamos doentes e nos interrogam quando
nós morremos
então nós não conseguimos nem nascer e
morrer sim as pessoas se nós pararmos
para pensar nessas palavras nós vamos
entender que são as pessoas que
legitimam a minha existência a sua
existência e validam os nossos
resultados é pra elas
elas são as destinatárias muitas vezes
dos nossos resultados nas pessoas que eu
me vejo me reconheço me fortaleço
é para elas que o ted existe que nós
possamos investir também em tecnologias
humanas para que nós sejamos cada vez
mais capazes de gerar conexão com as
pessoas e de perceber o outro na sua
essência mesmo que na rotina dos
afazeres do dia a dia que possamos
acreditar na força do coletivo e
entendamos que quando eu ajudo alguém a
elevar a sua autoconfiança
esta pessoa se capacita a fazer isso com
outras pessoas e com certeza todos nós
sentiremos os efeitos coletivos de mais
e mais feitos positivos no mundo com
certeza quando você lembra com muito
carinho de alguém que já não está mais
aqui é justamente por como essa pessoa
se relacionava com você como você se
sentia perto dela eram por suas
habilidades de relacionamento
e você como quer ser lembrado quando
aqui não mais estiver 100 porque este
mundo já estava aqui quando nós chegamos
e continuar aqui
quando saímos então quando você estiver
prestes a fazer a sua última avaliação
da sua vida como será o seu resultado
quantas pessoas você terá impactado pelo
incentivo doado a elas qual terá sido o
grande feito que você construiu nessa
existência
as pessoas que ficarem
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]